THIOMOST ABORTIONSRE I FIRST STH
ERSUS WADE, BUT
VOTERS WEIGHED ID CT
THASTATD TO
THERE. RIGHTS.MY NEXT A, IS ION
H MEE
ID
GEA,Y ABRAMS.
IT'S NICE TOEE IN PEON.
A LO GO STARWI STHAT'S HAPPENING
A  K ASP OG CLIMAT
BIDEN AGENDA, WHI KNOWOU
VERY MUCH PP I
THERE.
UNIVERSAL PRE-K, ED
CHILD TAX CREDIT.
WHAT'S Y  YOU TELS WHO ARE
OT IN THE
ISES THEY MADE IN HE
WASHINGTON?
I E RUNNINT
GOVERNOR, ITBOIN
>> WE KNOW VOTING IS, IT'S
WE HAVE TO KEEP TAKING IT, AND
THAT AILS SOCIETY.WHAT WEING HN
WASHINGTON RIGHT NOW IS THAT
OTHOS
LEGEORGIA WHEXUSE
BRIAN KEMP SO,
THIS DBI HELP A  BECAUSE IT'S G
D EIR
MEON WITHOUT CHOOSIN
AND FOO NEED TOAKE ACON
ON CLIMATE.
IVE INTEVERNOR HAS BEESOLUTEILI.
INF AMERICANS D THATD OF PROGRE
WE NEED TO CONTIE  LET ASK YOU
YOU'RE PUTTING F AENTER
R CAMPAIGN,
ABORTION ACCESS.
A PROMISE YOU
.ID, QUOTE,NEXT
GOVERNOR, I WILL MAKE
AND L TOAV
THBOD AFTER YBODY S, THEW IN
SIX  BETTETH ANYHE ROLE  GOVERN.
YOU HAVE TO WORK WITH TH
ATURE.
LEGISLATURE RIGHT NOW.
HO
>> I SVED FO11 YEARSN THGIAT AE.
I AM PROBAN TO
GET ANG FROM GEORGIA
CHAMBEOMMERCE.
I DEO NEGOTIATE
LAW.NAVIGATE.STAND  GEORGIANS DE
ANME'S
ERN
PECTRUM.
THE BILLSE 2019 BY ONE N THE HO.
I BELIEVTHE BACKIN POWER WHEN IE
RNH PEWANT TO DOHA
ABSOLUTELY BEL WFIX
TH.
>> AGA IN IS SOMEIN
REPUBLICANS HOLD OE, OF THE NG E
SEATS IN THE THERE.
ELECT AGOING TO BE A
IT IS GOING TO BE A
SIGNAL TO THE REMAINING
RIGHT BY THE WOMEN OF GEORGIA.
WILL INVESTIGATE WOMEN FOR SC
LOIT TELLS THEDANGER OING TOL I
ARE UND SOME
TYPE OLY IF TH
NG A GLASS OF WINE
ONHOOD.
THEIR LIKTS, THEY'RE IN DANGERG
RTVEL
GES IN THE
GI>> GEORGIA
CHILD  DEPENDENT ON TH
ST
WOULU T IF YOU NOR?OLUTELY.AT'S
WOMABEUNINVESTIGATION. PERSONHO
LIKELY BE CHD  MURDER IF
SO
CE T WE THIW WHAT THIS
GOAID HE WAN BANELE AN.
80 COUOUT OMEN IN ARDYUS
A THE
EXPERIENCE WITHOUT HINE,
E LEF ELIR
HUMAN .  AISTIAN.
SOMEISTIAN  DAUGF TWO D  METHODL
THGINS AT EPM JUSTNG T FAITHH RD
OUT MY F
GREAT DEALASNTI-ABONL COLLD I MT
REPRODUCTIVE CARD
ABORTION CARE REALLY IS.
ENALK ABOUT
AN EIE HAD BECAUSE
CTIVE.S ABLE TGIVE ME A
OVER TEXT FEW
LLY STARTED THINKING
ABOUT WHAT ROLE SHOULD AT, WHAT?
CONTROL HER BODYS RIGH
MOI PROTECT HEA
RIGHTSAT SHOULD BE M
>> JT TICAL
QUESTION.
FOA .OGHAM, SAID HE DOES NOTK EN
FO WHO COULD BLAME
WHEN THE BETWEEN
TWO 80- OR TWO
EA80-YEAR-OLDS FOR
TERM.E GE IN UN FOR ANHER
>> SHOULD PRESIDENT BIDE
2024? I'MRE HIM.E ICTOR OF WHA
WILL HAPPEN INS GOVERNORS
IN THIS COUNTRY NNES OF A S RIGO
CHOOSE, REDUCING GUNNCE,
MAKING SURE  ECONOMY
THAT IS ST ANT
T GOVERNOR
STRG HSAID, SHOULD
RUN?
BEST JOBND NOWOCHAS TO WHAT'S EN
YES, IF PRESIDENT BIDEN CHOOSES
MY RESPONSIBILITISO MAKE
CERTWE WOMEN
I ENCOURAGE WOMEN O TO MWEBSITEO
PLANS